this is the perfect morning routine
for all Christians.
1.
Do not answer the cell phone after m get up,
but first seek prayer to God.
as you start your day,
so will your day.
in that prayer you can thank God,
that you woke up well.
in that prayer you can God
therefore ask you to give strength for the day.
there are so many great morning prayers.
if you want me to make n video about it
then remove the plus.
Number 2,
how can you be any different?
Read the Bible.
oh just now that it's new year
there are so many great
New Year's bibelese plans for the whole year.
look for one online best
and begins to read
a little every morning.
it will enrich you like this.
Number 3 is,
take care of your physical temple.
get in the fresh air for 1 walk,
Do sports for half an hour.
very important,
drink your water.
I know you are all completely dehydrated.